Hello and welcome to this next video. In this we're going to be doing some of the coding.
We are going to be jumping into the Find Smart Object task and we're going to be accessing
the Smart Object subsystem for the first time. Okay, so the first thing I would like you to
do is to come down to the STT underscore Find Smart Object and double click to open it.
So here we have it here. As you look at this you can see that we already have the Interstate
showing and that is if you were creating this from scratch you wouldn't have it. You'd have to
get it from the overrides here in the drop down. But because we are trying to make this a bit
silica we've already dragged it in and added it. We've also created a number of the variables.
Bear in mind these variables are in the appropriate categories so we have context
for the character and the AI controller and we have the claim handle and the slot handle for the
output. These are so that they can be accessed through the state tree as part of the task and
can be populated. So let's see what code we've already got. So if I scroll out and come over to
the end here you can see that we have some code already here. We've got our finished task.
And this is required for us to tell the state tree that we have succeeded in this task.
But before it we have a little bit of code that is going to allow us to grab the claim handle
and the smart object subsystem and get the slots transform and save it to our AI.
AI is the BP NPC chairfinder. Now this probably isn't the best modular way of doing this but
we are going to need the transform. Probably using interface in other instances but I think
this shows what's going on quite well. We're going to need the transform in order to hand it
to the motion warping. So that is where we are going to move the mesh using root motion so that
it can sit down and perfectly interact with the chair. So warping is going to allow us to move
the skeletal mesh and make it so that when it sits down it actually sits down on the chair.
So all this is doing is if we get to this point we are grabbing the chairfinder and saving the
transform of the mesh so that it knows where to sit. Okay I am going to jump to the beginning here
and go through piece by piece. Now bear in mind there's always a finished version of the code
in the finished version folder so if you do get stuck you can jump in and get it but I encourage
you to copy alongs so that you understand what each of these nodes do. The first thing that we want
to do is find the smart objects. Now I am going to right-hand click and we are not going to be able
to find the smart object from here because it is a node which is part of the smart object subsystem.
So I am going to type in smart object and sub and that will bring me a option to get the smart
object subsystem. And once I have that I can drag off and I can search for find smart objects.
We are going to be finding multiple in this case and then selecting one random.
So that's the code that I need.
We will need to get the character to plug that into the use actor. This is the actor that is using it.
And now the next thing we need to do is make a request. So I am going to drag off of the request
pin and I am going to type make and you will see the only one that comes up is the make smart
object request. I need to drag off this request pin.
And as you can see as part of this make smart object request we have two inputs the query box
and the filter. We will start with the query box. What the query box is going to be is the spatial
so the locational size which we are going to search for a smart object. And if we look over this
this is of a box structure. So we need to make a box. I am going to drag off from there.
I am going to type in make and you will see at the bottom here we have make box.
Now for this to be a box we just need to give it a minimum vector a maximum vector.
However we need this to be relative to the AI. So this is in world space. I am going to grab my
hacked again and I am going to get actor location.
Drag that in and for the minimum I am going to do is I am going to minus.
So I am going to subtract and on the subtraction I am going to right hand click on the second input
pin and I am going to change that to a float double precision. I will plug that into the minimum.
Let's change it. I will do both of them first. I come up and I am going to do a plus and I am
going to add that into a maximum. I am going to convert both of these to a float.
And then I am going to type in literal
low. We will plug this in to both of the boxes. We could make this variable.
Well what this is going to do is it is going to allow me to just type in the squeeze of the box.
And for this I am going to go big. So I am going to put that in 20,000.
So that we definitely find something. Now it is very reasonable for that to be a smaller amount
and could make a variable included in the inputs so that we could change it at the point that we
are searching. But this will do for us at the time being.
So that gives us our query box. Now next we have the filter.
For this I am going to drive off and type make again and you see it has detected the pin that I
have got and it is suggesting make smart object request filter.
Now with this you can see that we have two pins down the left hand side.
A user tags and plane priority. I am actually not going to change either of these.
But I do need to do some inputting. So I am going to do the drop down that we have here.
And you can see that we have a number of different options.
It includes elements such as should include claim spots and should include disabled spots.
But I am just going to leave it with should evaluate conditions.
Now what we do need an input for which this is not going to function without
is the behavior definition classes. So in order to do that I am going to drag off
and do a make or a worry.
And for the make or a I am just going to select the game play behavior smart object definition.
That is all we need for the smart object filter. However do bear in mind that if you did want to
make something more advanced you could make a more complicated filter here in order to
create something a bit more complicated.
Grad wise we will up just a little bit with the smart object just for formatting.
So I will drag that up a little bit more and try and get it all on screen so I can just leave it
there for a second.
So this is our first section to find smart objects in the local area.
Right with that done let me jump on to the next section.
Now what we need to do is figure out if we are not getting any smart
objects because we want to return a failed condition if we don't have any smart objects.
So this is relatively simple we've got a return pin here if I hold down B for plush
I can connect that up and plug in the condition and if it is false we want to finish the task
but we want to finish the task as a fail.
We are quite straightforward if we have no object returned to all then we fail to find our smart.
Now next we want to mark slot as claimed and get main handle.
So we have all results here.
With this I am going to write off and I am going to type in random so we get a random array item.
Now you can see from this we have a smart object request result structure.
I am going to right hand click and you can see we have an option to split the struct pin.
I am going to do that because what we need is the slot handle.
It is not the smart object handle but just the specific slot because we might have multiple
slots on the actor and we want to work with that slot.
So I am going to now draw right off of the slot handle and type in mark smart object as claimed.
So we haven't returned any so we can now grab this and mark it as claimed.
Again we need a use actor so I will get my character,
to round it over so you have a little green line there and that plugs in perfectly.
Now the claim handle is actually part of our outputs.
Now we have our claim handle.
We might as well do the same thing on the other side.
So I am going to drag the claim handle, place it over the output pin
and it will automatically connect it up like this.
So we now have grabbed a random one of the slots and we have slamed it and set that claim handle
so that it can be as part of an output for this task.
So we have our final piece of code and this brings us to our final piece of code.
So all we need to do now is connect that up and that is our entire code done and dust it.
Now we cannot test this until we have got the other codes and bits of running.
I would believe that all makes sense.
You need to save and compile to check that there are no errors
and I am going to go back to my lab.
So thank you very much that brings us to the end of our first piece of coding.
The next one we are going to finish off the task that actually runs the behavior.